the autumn storms did nothing to put the
people off instead they gathered through
the day again in huge numbers
this is Beirut martyrs square the road
outside the mosque one focus for a
countrywide movement that cuts across
religion and politics for a week now
under their national flag their call has
been for the complete removal of the
government this is the road north out of
Beirut like so many it's blocked
peacefully by the people there is a
bizarre silence from the politicians
they want out leaving the army on the
streets and it seems not quite sure what
to do
at the moment the military and by
extension the government are doing
nothing to take the protesters off the
streets they were here a few scuffles
with the soldiers but it didn't last
long and quickly on social media the
military announced we are all there
beneath we are one family
the tune here is the Army's anthem sung
by the protesters 40 miles up the road
is Lebanon's second city Tripoli is long
seen as conservative religious not the
place anyone expected a secular uprising
and yet it has almost led the way this
past week the numbers here have been
consistent and pretty extraordinary by
evening the rain in Beirut had stopped
and the numbers had grown again why is
this such a huge moment you don't have
rights anymore as people we're lacking a
lot of rights and everything and
everything that we do we're working for
nothing we're actually leaving our
country to be able to have bright
outside abroad because we learn about
our rights here where does it go from
here now that the motivation and the
numbers are growing night by night and
their objective is to occupy squares and
streets in towns and cities right across
the country the political leaders remain
silent the national broadcaster has
remarkably been ignoring all this but no
one seems to care they've made their
mark they say they have changed Lebanon
in a week maybe but they haven't toppled
the government yet mark stone Sky News
in Lebanon